elle regarde des autres a changé parce
que subitement ils vous voient vous mais
en fait vous êtes presque transparent et
au travers de vous il voit votre part en
réalité
vous êtes Claude Chirac vous avez 29 ans
vous êtes la collaboratrice de votre
père
comment ça s'est comment ça s'est fait
tout de suite vous avez eu envie ou
rapidement de de faire de la politique
je fais pas de politique de toute
manière non ça se fait assez tardivement
même ça fait trois ans que je
travaillais avec lui
j'ai même assez longtemps hésité à le
faire dans la mesure où je me demandais
si c'était si ce serait facile
ou du moins ça ne serait pas gênant de
d'avoir une relation et privée et
professionnelle à gérer en même temps
c'est vous qui avez décidé ou c'est
votre père c'est lui qui m'a demandé
c'est lui qui en a parlé le premier qui
en a reparlé et reparlé
jusqu'au jour où encore une fois je
pensais que en fait c'est lui qui avait
sans doute raison et c'est vrai que
l'expérience c'est extrêmement
enrichissante qui veut dire que vous
avez adhéré un village adulte au même
idée celle de votre père pas forcément
il y a quand même un tronc commun
forcément mais pas forcément non
donc pour moi c'est enfin moi je sais je
travaille beaucoup je suis très
affective alors je veux dire je le vis
plus comme
comme une
un homme avec qui on travaille et que
l'on accompagne sur un certain d'une
certaine route que comme une adhésion
est-ce que vous êtes opposé à lui sur
certains points sur
bien sûr
mais pas uniquement dans le domaine
politique d'ailleurs et alors vous de
donc de porter le nom de Chirac
qu'est-ce que pour vous c'est un
avantage ou un inconvénient vous le
vivez comment
je crois qu'on lui différemment d'abord
selon les âges
moi ça m'a jamais posé vraiment de
difficultés par ce que d'abord j'étais
élevé très très à l'écart de
de ce monde de cette vie professionnelle
l'homme politique c'est quand même un
personnage particulier parce que c'est
celui qui attire il y a beaucoup plus de
passion d'amour et de haine que pour un
comédien c'est plus exacerbé peut-être
oui peut-être et encore peut-être dans
la haine peut-être oui voilà passion je
sais pas mais dans la haine c'est
peut-être plus fort plus
plus exacerbée pour un politique est-ce
que vous aussi votre père vous a manqué
dans la mesure où il avait des activités
extérieures importantes
il a pas été très présent c'est certain
tout toutes les personnes que j'ai une
activité professionnelle prenante
forcément pas très présent chez eux
c'est en général le prix à payer mais il
a su
les rares moments où on était ensemble
il a su les vivre intensément et nous
les faire vivre intensément lorsque
votre père a été donc Premier ministre
vous aviez 12 ans 12 ans et demi comment
vous avez réagi parce que là c'était
quelque chose qui se passait
intérieurement pour moi non encore une
fois parce que c'était vraiment de
de vie qui était complètement dissociée
moi je vivais ma vie à moi n'a
absolument pas été changée en revanche
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est le
regard des autres qui peut
éventuellement changer et ce regard des
autres vous l'avez ressenti comment
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs de ce
moment là
non mais le regard des autres a changé
parce que subitement il vous voit vous
mais en fait vous êtes presque
transparent et au travers de vous il
voit votre part en réalité il vous parle
et en fait il parle cette comme un écran
mais ça ça doit être intolérable non à
vivre
non mais on la prend on le découvre et
puis sans doute c'est curieux au départ
c'est parfois blessant puis après on
comprend on apprend et
moi ce que j'entends dans ce que vous
dites c'est comme si on apprenait à
disparaître et vous aussi vous êtes très
effacés comme ça non c'est à dire que
les gens vous parlent comme si vous vous
étiez donc si vous n'existez pas mais
c'est à vous de d'avoir de bien
comprendre
et puis de trouver une autre manière de
notre manière de de vivre de continuer à
avancer vous avez eu le sentiment comme
comme Olivier parfois d'être utilisé
oui
oui bien sûr c'est un peu le le problème
de l'écran c'est-à-dire que on vous
parle à vous en espérant bien et très
bêtement d'ailleurs que vous allez faire
passer un message vous êtes laissé je
dirais avoir quelquefois bien sûr
bien sûr
pas très souvent finalement mais
suffisamment en tout cas pour avoir opté
pour un chemin oui plus plus solitaire
plus je retiré
ça vous a contraint à ça
plus solitaire et réservée que
donc c'est quand même c'était ma nature
mais
oui ça a sans doute développé ce côté là
chez moi oui quand vous avez senti que
vous avez été utilisé après coup c'est
quoi c'est ma blessé quand on est petit
ou même quand on est adolescent quand on
aborde des relations même amoureuses et
que on a des convenu
mais c'est bien parce que ça permet
d'apprendre peut-être beaucoup plus vite
que quelqu'un d'autre je parle peu très
peu de moi
je pense que c'est pas ça peut pas
intéresser des gens
vous avez toujours été comme ça
la télévision ou même jamais
oui mais il y a pas vraiment de raison
de vivre
quelque chose je voulais savoir si vous
en avez parlé à votre père que vous
faisiez cette émission ou pas
disons je l'ai informé mais on en a pas
vraiment parlé
et vous pensez qu'il va la regarder oui
je pense oui je pense
est-ce que il y a quelque chose comme ça
que vous pensez lui dire à travers la
mission ou c'est simplement vous venez
simplement parler
on n'a jamais parlé vraiment de tout ça
on est plutôt très pudique dans notre
famille donc on n'a jamais vraiment
parlé de tout ça mais
là encore comme ça à jamais été vraiment
un problème mal vécu
j'ai aucun message à faire passer toute
façon si j'en avais un je pense que je
vais lui dirai cela peut-être pas été
toujours le cas aujourd'hui je pense que
je vais lui dire
j'ai une chance immense c'est d'avoir
une qualité de relation très importante
et peut-être pas très fréquente mais
très très forte
et donc
oui bien sûr il y a des choses il y a
des choses qui ont été je pense
poursuivre quand même votre père comme
ça sans sans compter les problèmes
politiques qui peuvent avoir entre vous
c'est que il y a forcément une adoration
quoi
vous avez de l'admiration pour votre
père oui pour l'être humain bien sûr
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]